[موسيقى]
عامه المظاهرات الغاضبه مناطق سيطره
المعارضه شمال غربيه سوريا خلال الايام
القليله الماضيه مذكره بتلك التي خرجت
ثوره السوريه غير ان هذه المظاهرات كانت
هذه المره ضد اي مصالحه بين تركيا والنظام
السوري ضد الحديث عن اعاده اللاجئين
السوريين مصيره ملايين اللاجئين السوريين
في تركيا وملايين النازحين في شمال سوريا
[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم الحديث عن مصير ملايين
اللاجئين والنازحين السوريين في تركيا
وعلى حدود البلدين دوا في ارجاء المنطقه
وعاد الى الواجهه بقوه هذه المره
الدفاع روسيا وسوريا وتركيا في موسكو
مؤخرا وبعد تصريحات متعاقبه لمسؤولين
اتراك تشير الى افاق التقارب مع النظام
السوري ابرزها ما قاله الرئيس اردوغان بان
مسيره جديده بدات من خلال هذا الاجتماع
لوزاره الخارجيه دون ان يستبعد اجتماعا
على مستوى رؤساء الدول
عن مصير اللاجئين السوريين والنازحين في
تركيا وعلى حدود البلدين بعد التقارب
التركيه السوريه وكيف ستتعامل المعارضه
السوريه مع هذا الموضوع يسعدنا ان يكون
معنا في هذه الحلقه هنا في الاستديو
الدكتور مضر الدبس الكاتب والباحث السياسي
السوري من انقره الدكتور محمد عاطف
كرشيزين عضو مجلس الامن والسياسات
الخارجيه في الرئاسه التركيه ومن موسكو
المحلل السياسي الروسي يفجيني
صيغه تفاهم مع النظام السوري بشان مناطق
سيطره الاكراد قرب الحدود التركيه
بظلالها على مشهد الثوره السوريه وبات
مصيره ملايين اللاجئين والمهاجرين موضعه
تساؤل الملح في حال نجحت مساعي تطبيق
العلاقات بين انقره ودمشق
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هل ستكفي صيحات ولا التي ينادي بها هؤلاء
السوريون لوقف ما يعتقد انه مساله تطبيع
العلاقات بين تركيا والنظام السوري
بالنسبه للانقره فان الاشور القليله
المقبله حاسمه لتحقيق شيء ما قبل موعد
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه في
حزيران يونيو المقبل
فالمساله السوريه بكل تشعوباتها جزء من
مشكله الاتراك واهتماماتهم وربما ستؤثر
كثيرا في اتجاهات التصويت
اردوغان الطامحه لولايه رئاسيه جديده
لقاء وزراء الخارجيه كما يبدو قريبا جدا
وربما
بلقاء تاريخيا بين اردوغان والاسد وبوتين
[موسيقى]
هذا ما يتظاهر ضده هؤلاء انه عقد كامل من
الزمن تحمل فيه البطش والنزوح والتهجير
فقتل منهم من قتل وسيق كثيرون الى معتقلات
النظام وسجنه
فهل ستؤول الامور الى ما يخشون مصالحه اهم
حالف لهم مع النظام
يقولون لاي دعوه قد تصدر عن انقره
للسوريين من اجل الانخراط في مسار
دبلوماسي مع النظام
لا تغير في المواقف ولم يتحدث احد عن
تطبيق او مصالحه حتى وان نفى رئيس
الائتلاف السوري المعارض سالم المسلم حديث
الحكومه التركيه عن اي تطبيع او مصالحه
فانما يريده اردوغان من دمشق قد لا يتحقق
دون ذلك انه يريد بالاساس تعديل في اتفاق
اضنه الذي تم التوصل اليه عام
1998 بان تمد المنطقه الامنه الشماليه
السوريه بعمق 30 كم من الحدود التركيه
كفيل ذلك بتبديل المخاوف التركيه من
طموحات الاكراد الذين يتمتعون باداره
ذاتيه في تلك المناطق
لكن خلف كل هذه الحسابات السياسيه
والانتخابيه قضايا ملايين اللاجئين
والنازحين الذين باتوا ورقه انتخابيه
حاسمه في السياسه التركيه
يخشى انهم يواجهون مصيرا مجهوله سيظل
معلقا الى ان يعرف ما اذا كانت مساعي
اردوغان ستكلل بالنجاح قبل موعد
الانتخابات ام لا
واي كانت نتيجه هذا المسار الدبلوماسي فان
اطياف المعارضه السوريه تقف على مفترق طرق
بين السياسات الحليف التركي من جهه واوراق
التفاوض التي باتت في حوزه النظام وداعمه
من جهه ثانيه
وتمسك هؤلاء بثورتهم من جهه ثالثه
[تصفيق]
دكتور مدرب دبس اهلا وسهلا بك
عندما نشاهد كل هذه المظاهرات الغاضبه
بالنسبه لهؤلاء سواء اللاجئين او النازحين
ما الذي يخشونه حقيقه عن حقيقه عندما
يسمعون بهذا الحديث المتنامي عن امكانيه
مصالحه بين انقره ودمشق
يخشون على حياتهم اولا بعد كل الذي راوه
وكل الذي حصل ويخشون على مستقبلهم ومستقبل
ابنائهم بعد ان قدموا تضحياتهم يمكن يعني
من اعظم تضحيات هذا هذا القرن ثم يشعرون
بالكثير من خيبه الامل الحقيقه من هذا
التقارب الذي الذي يلوح في ال- في الافق
خيبه الامل بسببها ان تركيا قد استثمرت ان
اردنا التعبير بهذه الطريقه في العمق
الوجداني السوري وكانت دائما في صف هذا
السوري العادي وبالمناسبه السوري العادي
اوعى سياسيه من هذه المعارضه التي تمثله
اليوم وهذه المعارضه التي بطبيعه الحال
تتكلم مع الدول شكلت فجوه بينما يمكن ان
نسميه طموح السوري وما يريد السوري من هذه
الثوره وبينما ارادت او او الطريقه التي
انتقتها هذه المعارضه لتمثيل السوري
العادي او لترجمه شعاراته وسلوكه همم ووضع
الاجتماعي
الى السياسه بهذا المعنى لديه خيبه امل قد
عبر عنها بشكل واضح بانه بانه همم يعني
نحن اصحاب القضيه هكذا كان الشعار يعني
نحن نمتلك هذه القضيه هذا حقيقه لا يحيج
على الدول فحاسب سواء كانت تركيه ام غير
تركيا انما ايضا يحيل على على يعني ال-
ال- ال- الشارع قد ضاق درعا ممارسه
المعارضه ليس من حق المعارضه ولم نكن لنصل
لهنا تركيا دوله سياده وتركيا حره
بالنهايه بما تفعل ونحن نستطيع ان نخاطب
تركيا الان بوضع في سوريا يعني في وضع ضعف
نستطيع ان نخاطبها بالخطاب القيم الانساني
ولكن العتب الكبير ايضا على المعارضه التي
ساهمت بشكل او باخر بان نصل الى هذه
النقطه التي ادت الى ان ان ان ان تكون جزء
من السياسه السوريه يمتلك هذا الاخر سواء
هذا كان الاخر صديق او عدوه يعني هؤلاء
المهجرين اللاجئين النازحين لا يتصورون
ابدا امكانيه العوده تحت هذا النظام يعني
مثلا تجربه درعه يبدو كانت معبره الذين
عادوا بعضهم تعرضا للقتل بعضهم تعرضا
للتعذيب هل هذا نموذج مثل في في اذهانهم
ما سمعته منهم البارحه قد تواصلت مع
مجموعه من الذين كانوا على الارض وكان
هناك اجماع على نقطه واحده همم وهي واضحه
جدا انه ليس لدينا همم ما نخسر يعني اكثر
من ذلك فلن نعود لهذا النظام تحت اي شيء
باي شكل من الاشكال ولا يهمنا ان كان
سيذهب اردوغان او ستذهب المعارضه او ايا
كان
وتفاجات ايضا بمثل اخرى حقيقه همم ان
الخطاب السياسي متقدم جدا والفهم السياسي
لما يحدث متقدم في الشارع من هذا الانسان
السوري العادي بحيث انه لن تنطلع عليه بعد
اليوم كل هذه المسائل غير المنطقيه يعني
على سبيل المثال لا ينطلق عليه اليوم اا
مساله انه انه التطمينات التي تصلوا من
الاعتلاف انه لن يكون هناك تصالح كما
سمعنا لرئيس الائتلاف الان لانه ال- ال-
الخطاب كله غير غير غير منطقي يعني ان
كانت لا تريد تركيا الذهاب من دون
المعارضه فهي ذهبت الان والمعرضه لا تريد
الذهاب يعني همم ولكن هذه التطبينات ايضا
جاءت حتى من الجانب التركي نسال الدكتور
محمد عاكفير جديد يعني سواء تصريحات وزير
الخارجيه احمد شوقي شغله او تصريحات وزير
الدفاع خلال روسيا كا- كلها تؤكد على انه
لن يجبر احد على العوده اي عوده ستكون
توعيه وهمم بشكل محترم وامن لماذا رغم كل
هذه التطمينات لا يوجد شعور بالارتياح لدى
السوريين سواء في الشمال الغربي السوري او
داخل تركيا
صعبه جدا بالنسبه لتركيا ذلك بسبب
الانتخابات القادمه وبسبب
السياسي
والسكاني في تركيا بسبب كل هذه الظروف
تحاول تركيا ان تفتح امكانيات
النازحين الناس السوريين النازحين في
تركيا واولا وقبلك الشرطه الاساسي للحكومه
هو لعوده السوريين الى سوريا الى وطنهم
فقط
الذي التي ابتعدوا عنها منذ 10 سنوات
واكثر اذا
لديهم ضد افعال مختلطه وتباينه حول هذا
القرار
وما يمكن نسميها هذا التقارب وطبعا ان
تركيا تستثمر كبيرا في امن حدودها وكذلك
في امنه وسلامه الناس الذين يعيشون
لكن نتذكر ان
الامر ليس كما كانت عليه الوضع قبل 11 سنه
منزل 2010
الكثير الامور قد تغيرت تركيا تحاول ان
تقدم
من جد اخر او لحل مشكله الامن همم لكن
هناك حرب كبيره جاريه عندما قرر روسيا
غزوه اوكرانيا ذلك اثر على تركيا وايضا
وعلى اقتصاد تركيا وبالتالي نحن في وضع
صعب بالنسبه للمناخ السياسي التركي لوضع
صعب جدا
وهناك فعلا هناك فعلا حزب جديد ظهر في
البيئه السياسيه التركيه لم يكن موجوده
سابقا وهذا الحزن يدعو بشكل مستمر بل حتى
يدعو الى العوده القسريه للسوريين الى
بلادهم اذا في جهود لمنعه هذه
الابعاد او النقل للقصري للسوريين تحاول
تركيا حاليا الان تمهد الطريق
ليس فقط في تركيا ولكن ايضا عندما
اخذوا اوعدوا الى سوريا همم طبعا همم هذا
الموضوع همم سيد يمكنني سيديروف لا يخص
فقط النظام السوري وتركيا ايضا همم روسيا
داخل على الخط وتعتبر نوعا ما هي الضامنه
للنظام السوري وهي التي تسعى لاعاده
تاهيله هل هل يوجد لدى صاحب القرار في
موسكو رؤيه معينه لموضوع اللاجئين في ضوء
هذا الحديث عن مصالحه مع النظام
بين تركيا وايران بين تركيا ونظام اقصد
طبعا نعم
نعم تحيه لكم وليساعد المشاهدين والديك
الكريمين اعتقد بان روسيا لديها تصور واضح
حول موضوع التعامل مع اللاجئين ولكن الكره
هنا يجب ان تكون ايضا في ملعب النظام
السوري منذ سنتين تقريبا او اكثر بقليل
بذلت موسكو اول محاوله لعقد مؤتمر خاص
بقضايا اللاجئين انا ذاك نحن راينا مقاطعه
غربيه لهذا المؤتمر وهذا كان يعني ان
روسيا ربما يجب ان تتحمل الجزء الاساسي من
همم النفقات الخاصه
باعاده الاعمار وقضيه توظيف اللاجئين وغير
ذلك ناهيك عن قضايا امنيه وهي ربما
الاساسيه فيما يتعلق بعوده اللاجئين الان
يبدو ان روسيا تحاول ان تطرح هذا الموضوع
هذا الملف همم
مره ثانيه بعد ان تلقت ربما من تركيا همم
موافقه مبدئيه على المشاركه الى جانب
روسيا في هذه القضيه بشط جوانبها
وبشات همم
الامور التي تتعلق بهذه القضيه ولكن حتى
اذا تم توصل الى اتفاق نهائي حول هذا همم
الموضوع وحتى اذا وافقت دمشق مبدئيا عليها
فهناك شروط لا يمكن ان تقبل بها دمشق وهي
كما قال همم في اخر تصريحه الرئيس السوري
بشار الاسد لا يمكن لاي لقاءات سوريه
تركيه ان تكون الا بعد انهاء الاحتلال
وكان يقصد بذلك طبعا الاحتلال التركي ولكن
في ظل اسرار تركيا على
ضروره بقائها في منطقه امنه وسيطره عليه
وفي شمال
سوف يكون من الصعب على موسكو همم ايجاد
قاسم مشترك بين مواقف انقره ودمشق وهنا لا
شك ان روسيا عليها ان تبذل الكثير همم من
الجهود
لكي تتكلم جهودها بنجاح في اخر المطاف
طالما انه من الصعب همم دكتور دبس البحث
عن همم نقاط التقاء بين تركيا
وسوريا مثل ما قال همم يعني بالنسبه همم
التصريح الاخيره الذي اشار اليه تصريح
الرئيس بشار الاسد
تحدث عن ضروره انهاء الاحتلال ووقف ما
سماه بدعم الارهاب في هذه الحاله بتقديرك
النظام لا يقيم اي وزن لموضوع اعاده
اللاجئين لان همم كثيرون يعتقدون بان
النظام اصلا لا يرغب في عودته لان اولا
همم هناك اعباء ماليه وخدميه هو ليس
مستعدا لتقديمها ونقطه اخرى هو يعتقد ان
هؤلاء اصلا كتله معاديه له فلماذا يقبل
بها ان تعود الى ارضه هل هذا يجب وضعه في
الحسبان
تقدير جزء كبير من هذا الكلام صحيح يعني
هو لا ينظر الى اللاجئين بوصفهم كتله
معاديه فحسب انما يعني عندما يتكلم عن
الارهاب حقيقه هو يتكلم عن السوريين
بالنسبه للنظام كل سوري معارض هو ارهابي
بهذا المعنى هو ينظر الى ال- الى اللاجئين
فلا يرغب بعودتهم وجزء كبير من هذا الكلام
صحيح ولكن ايضا استخدام كلمات مثل
الاحتلال على سبيل المثال حقيقه تركيا
متواجده في في بعض المناطق في سوريا بظروف
في ادركها النظام جيدا يمكن ان نسميها
يعني ولكن هي ليست احتلال بطبيعه الحال
واذا اردنا ان نتعامل بنفس المنطق
فالاحتلال الحقيقي هو الحقيقه انا
الاحتلال الروسي والطائرات الروسيه التي
كانت تقصف الاطفال الابرياء على الاقل
تركيا لم تقتل الاطفال الابرياء في في في
سوريا
وايضا الايرانيون يعني الايرانيون لا لا
لا لا لا يسميه المحتلين يعني هل يجرا هذا
النظام ان يقول انه محتل الايرانيين وان
قراره السياسي يتخذ في ايران وفي وفي
موسكو بهذا المعنى هذا لاعب على على
المصطلحات بطبيعه الحال ثم بالحديث عن
الانتخابات يعني في تركيا بالشق الاخر من
الموضوع الان السوري العادي الحقيقه يشعر
بانه هو ليس ورقه انتخابيه ويشعر بمثله
اخرى ايضا مهما يعني نحن نحترم القرار
وبطبيعه الحال كل سوري عاش في تركيا او لم
يعش في تركيا هو بشكل او باخر تركيا قد
حفرت في وجدان 2011 الى اليوم شيئا ما فله
اقرباء هناك وزاره اقربائه على الاقل مره
واصبح هناك ارتباط وجداني من نوع هذا
الارتباط الوجداني يجعلنا نخاف ايضا نحن
على على الاتراك يعني عندما نقول انتخابات
اليوم ويقول ان هناك حزبا يريد ترحيل
اللاجئين هناك معارضه الان
المطلوب بال- كما نفهم في الدول
الديمقراطيه وفي العقلانيه الديمقراطيه ان
تقنع الناخب بما تراه صحيحه نحن نعرف ان
ما يراء حزب العداله والتنميه صحيحه ان هو
ما قاله دائما باننا لن نعيد اللاجئين الى
القتل فاذا كان هذا قاتله هل من المنطق من
اجل يعني ما هذه الدعايه الانتخابيه يسال
اي سوريا عادي ما هي الدعايه الانتخابيه
ما نوع هذه الدعايه الانتخابيه التي
تجعلنا نضع يدنا بيد السفاح التي قلت اننا
لن نسمح له بحماه جديده وقلت انه قاتل نضع
يدنا بيده من اجل الورقه انتخابيه هناك
طريق اخر ان تقنع يعني اكيد انت مقتنع به
لانه مقتنع حزب العداله والتنميه بهذه
الخطاب من 2011 اليوم مصيبه بما انك مقتنع
ان همم اقنع ناخبك بدلا من ان تتوجه
وتتمنى خطاب المعارضه بهذا الشكل لو ربحت
الانتخابات
بعد ان تحولت الى الى الى معارضك فهو قد
ربح بك وهو الذي يجلس على الحكم لانه يعني
اذا كان يريد ترحيل اللاجئين فانت رحلت
اللاجئين ويريد امور اخرى فهذه هذه
الديمقراطيه منزوعه العقلانيه حقيقه وهذه
فمها السوري تماما وبالاضافه ان عذاباتنا
يا سيدي ونحن الان نقول على اننا اصحاب
الم عذباتنا لا تصلح باي شكل من الاشكال
لايت لين تكون ورقه انتخابيه لا من صديق
ولا من عدو وفي الحقيقه يعني صحيح ان
السوري الان لديه ركاكه في التمثيل
السياسي من قبل هذه المعارضه التي بطبيعه
الحال اصبحت يعني تسمع كلام ال- ال- الدول
بدلا من ان تكون لها النت
ولكن على ايه حال يعني ما زال هناك في
الافق ان كان لولاده
نتحدثين نريد ان نعرف من هم يعيش ملايين
اللاجئين السوريين في تركيا وينتشرون في
العديد من المقاطعه والعشرات من المدن
يتركز جزء كبير من هؤلاء في المدن
الحدوديه حيث الوطن القريب البعيد
والاشقاء الناجحون في المناطق المحادثه
يقدر عدد النازحين السوريين في شمال غرب
سوريا بنحو مليون و800,000 شخص حسب منظمات
دوليه ويعيش هؤلاء في مخيمات المنتشره
بالمناطق الخاضعه لسيطره المعارضه السوريه
شمال غرب سوريا على الحدود السوريه
التركيه اما اعداد اللاجئين السوريين في
تركيا فتقدر حاليا بنحو ثلاثه ملايين
و500,000 شخص
ويعيش هؤلاء اللاجئون في عشرات المدن
التركيه حيث قامت الحكومه التركيه ومنذ
سنوات بتفكيك المخيمات ونقل اللاجئين الى
داخل المدن التركيه في اسطنبول وحدها يعيش
نحو
550,000 لاجل بينما يعيش اغلب اللاجئين في
المدن الحدوديه مع سوريا ففي غاز عنتاب
وهتاري اورفا يوجد نحو مليون و200000
ويعيش حوالي ربع مليون لاجئ في كل من اضنه
ومرسين وفي مدينه بورصه يوجد نحو 200,000
بينما يعيش في ازمير نحو 150 الف لاجل
ويتوزع مئات الالاف من اللاجئين على مدن
عده اخرى منها قونيا وكليس وانقره
وكههرمان مرش وماردين وديار بكر وغيرها
وبين اللاجئين السوريين نحو 200,000 حصلوا
على الجنسيه التركيه بينما عاد نحو 500
الف لاجئين سوري من تركيا الى المناطق
الخاضعه لسيطره المعارضه في شمالي سوريا
[موسيقى]
ما اشرتي اليه الدكتور دبس من موضوع
الورقه الانتخابيه في هذا الموضوع نسال
عنه الدكتور محمد عاكفكار جديده وانت اشرت
قبل القليل لان هناك حزب اصلا يريد طرد
هؤلاء اللاجئين وهناك احزاب اخرى تطرح
تصورات مرحليه لعوده هؤلاء كيف يمكن
لتركيا الان ان تدير هذا الموضوع بعيدا عن
الحسابات الانتخابيه القريبه لانتخابات
يونيو المقبل
في الواقع
التوجه نحو انتخابات لابد ان تهتم بكل
الصمعه المنافسين على الارض وهذه المشكله
ضد
الهجره يدعو بشكل
الانتخابات
والاقتصاد
يعاني من صعوباته خليفه فان هذا الموضوع
اصبح موضوع عن هشه ضعيفا امام الناخبين
فان الحكومه التركيه تقول
الى اين سترسلونهم اذا ما فعلتم ذلك فهل
ساحرون باي ظروف جيدا العيش بشكل كريم هل
هناك
هل هناك محلات
اذا ما قرر السوريون العوده الى همم
بلادهم او لا فهذا الموضوع اخر في الحكومه
التركيه ترى انه هناك خطه جاهزه ليس فقط
بوكس وبالتالي فاء المحادثات الجاريه
حاليا بين روسيا وتركيا وسوريا
هذه الارضيه لمن لمن يرغب ويقبل بالعوده
الى سوريا هذه الفكره السوريه
[موسيقى]
كذب على قرار الامم المتحده 20 20 20
او قرار مجلس الامن حول
حقوق السوريين بالعيش في وطنهم اذا هذا
طبعا يتطلب جهودا كبيره من قبل
الاطراف الثالث
بامان
في بيئه امنه مؤمنه والموضوع والمشكله
الاخرى هي ان القوات التركيه
تناقش هل هل تسحب من الاراضي السوريه
الحمد لله
المفاوضات الجاريه بين الحكومه السوريه
والحكومه التركيه عندما واذا ما شعرت
تركيا بان سلامتهم مضمون
سلامه
الملائمه للعيش لمن يرغب بالعوده ويدون
ذلك اما اذا ارادوا الوقاء في الصلاه
التي تشير اليها نقطه هامه اريد ان اسال
عنها
وهي مساله ان اي عوده للاجئين يجب ان تتم
بالتنسيق طبعا مع النظام
ولكن النظام السوري همم ليس في وارد ال-
ال- الحساباته الان على الاقل هذا الموضوع
هنا اسالك السيد سيدي روف واستشهد بمقاله
اخر سفير تركي في في سوريا همم عمر همم
يقول همم هنا اقتباس يقول ليس لتركيا ان
تحدد متى وكيف ينبغي ان يعوده هؤلاء سوريا
هي مصدر المشكن وستكون ايضا مصدر الحل لكن
النظام وعقليته لا تزال كما كانت عام 2011
ما الذي يمكن لموسكو ان تفعله اذا كانت
الصوره بهذا الشكل
طبعا موسكو تواجهه يعني مشكله صعبه جدا في
اقناع النظام اوروبا مراقبه في ذلك كيفيه
تنفيذ بعض تعهدات التي يمكن ان تقطع على
نفسها الحكومه السوريه فيما يتعلق بظروف
الامنيه او ضمادات الامنيه التي يجب ان
تقدم لللاجئين من الصعب جدا يعني التاكد
من كيفيه تنفيذ السلطات السوريه لمصر هذه
التعاقدات ان اعطيت طبعا اثناء الاتصالات
العديده التي تجري بينها وبين موسكو
وبالتالي انا اقول وعود فاقول ان مهمه
موسكو صعب للغايه في هذا الشعر ولكن لابد
من
همم هذه العمليه ان تبدا من اي خطوه وطبعا
انا وشاطر اليك الذين يقولون بان عوده
اللاجئين يجب ان تكون على اساس او على
اساس مبدا تطوعي لا يمكن اجبار احد على
العوده الى البلد هذا اولا ثانيا لبده
طبعا من همم اعداد وتحضير البنيه التحتيه
المطلوبه التي سوف تتيح الي هؤلاء
اللاجئين الى جانب طبعا تقديمهم ضمانات
امنيه تتيح لهم امكانيه ايجاد فرصه العمل
والتوظيف وما الى ذلك كل هذه الامور تتطلب
همم جهوده اضافيه وربما اجتماع الاجتماع
الذي عقد في نهايه السنه الماضيه على
مستوى وزراء الدفاع ورؤساء الجهاز همم
الاجهزه الامنيه للبلدان الثلاثه همم كان
قد اتخذ قرارات بتشكيل عده اللجان وهذه
اللجان طبعا يجب ان تبدا همم بشكل همم
دقيق
للالتزام بكل ما يتم الاتفاق عليه ولكن
حتى نتائج هذه الاجتماعات لن تكون فعاله
الا اذا ترجمت على ارض الواقع وهنا بتربيه
الحال لا يمكن لموسكو وحدها ان تتابع هذا
الموضوع وانما تقوم بذلك بالتنسيقه مع
تركيا هذا الامر ايضا يصعب تنفيذه الان في
ظروف الحاليه حينما همم نرى ان موسكو
مشغوله تماما بالازمه الاوكرانيه وهذا
يتطلب منها ربما ال- همم غسل المزيد من
الجهود لكي ترفع عن كاهيلها الجزء من
المشاهد مشاغل التي ترتبط بمشارتها في
التعامل مع الازمه السوريه اذا تكللت هذه
الجهود بنجاح فستكون بالسهوله من السهوله
بمكان بالنسبه لموسكو ان تترك دمشق وانكره
ااا تتواصل الان وتتفاعلان بعضها مع البعض
لحل هذه المشكلات ولكن عمليه هذه القضيه
في غايه الصعوبه الان اذا سيد دكتور دبس
تركيا في وضع صعب روسيا في وضع صعب
المعارضه السوريه ايضا في وضع صعب يعني
اذا اخذنا ما قاله وزير الدفاع التركي خلو
سيار يقول هنا انا اقتباس يقول هم اخوتنا
ولا نتحدث عن اي امر يقصد السوريين
والمعارضه السوريه ولا نتحدث عن اي امر او
قرار يمكن ان يضعهم في موقف صعب
ولكن عمليه لهم في موقف صعب الان وهناك من
يقول تركيا لا تعلم اصلا حتى المعارضه
السوريه ولا تنسق معها هي تعلمها فقط بما
استقر عليه الراي في هذه الحاله كيف على
المعارضه ان تتصرف
يعني المشكله الرئيسيه التي تعاني منها
سوريا مع المعارضه هي نفس المشكله التي
نعاني منها مع النظام باستثناء طبعا
الجانب الاخلاق يعني فرق كبير المشكله
تتلخص في كلمه واحده انها همم تتبنى
مقاربات لا سياسيه يعني الكلام عن النظام
طبعا هو نظام كبتاجوني بما تحمل كلمه
الكبتاجون من اخلاقيه ومن من شكل عصابه
العصابه لا تعمل في السياسه يعني ولا وهي
غير مؤهله بطبيعه الحال لتتكلم مع الدول
في عصر الحدث
ومنها دول ديمقراطيه الان النظام حقيقه
المشكله انه عفوا المعارضه المشكله ايضا
انها منزوعه ال- ال- السياسه يعني
نستطيع ان نقول انها لا تتعامل بشكل سياسي
وانها حشره اصدقاءها في الزاويه نتيجه
الان هذا الكلام اصبح همم يعني
يعني اصبح اصبح السوريون يتجراون على قوله
وهو بطبيعه الحال يتم الكلام به الان
الاجدى والاجدر ان ان تقف هذه المعارضه
على الاقل امام التناقضات يعني كما قلت
لكم هناك طلاق واضح وصريح بان نقول نحن لم
نذهب رغما عن المعارضه طيب ما انتم رحتوا
اذا هي المعارضه موافقه يا اما ذهبتم رغما
عنها هذه مسائل يجب ان توضح بكل شفافها
الى السوريين الثوره السوريه كما يفهمها
السوري العادي هي ثوره عموميه للانتزاع
الحريه وهذا الجانب العلانيه والاعلان هو
اهم شيء الان الان اذا استمر هذا الوضع في
هذا الاداء الرقيق للمعارضه فبطبيعه الحال
سوريا خارج المعادله يعني الان لا احد
يفكر بالسوريين نتيجه غياب السوريين
السياسي السياسيه
وصفت اداءها بالركيك ولكن اذا تجاوزنا
موضوع عن الركاكه وارادت ان تكون عمليه
وناجعه ماذا عساها تفعل يعني انا انا انصح
هذه المعارضه على سبيل المثال ان تتوجه
اليوم ان تعود الى الذات يعني بدلا من ان
نستجدي الدول بطبيعه الحال نحن لا نملك
القرار تركي ولكن على الاقل نمرك القرار
السوري يعني هذه العوده الى ذات العوده
الى السوريين اطلاق حوار عمومي سوري يعني
لا احد يدعي انه مهمه المعارضه سهله وهي
لا تقوم بهذه المهمه نحن نواجه مشكله
معقده ومعقده جدا ولكن الحقيقه الوحيده
التي كانت تبدو واضحه خطيره هذه السنين ان
هذه المشكله تحتاج الى حوار في فضاء عمومي
سوري كان مطلوبا من هذه المعارضه ان تتبنى
هذا الفضاء العمومي السوري وما زال الى
اليوم لا يطلب منها الا مساله واحده فقط
يمكن ان تسميها مساله القبائل السياسيه
كان هذا كان هذا الشارع يعني همم
المساله كانت حب لانشات بمولود بمولود
الوطنيه السوريه بالجمهوريه الجديده
بالزمن السوري الجديد كان المطلوب من هذه
المعارضه القباله والان مطلوب منها
القبائل يعني عندما تنظر في الشمال تجد
هذا الوعي السياسي الالتفات الى الشباب
انهاء المساله الايديولوجيه يعني ما زال
هذا ما نسميه السوري المقلوب لا يمكن
اليوم امام
ظاهره مثل الثوره السوريه تحيل على على
شكل جديد من التفكير الجمهور ان شاء الله
التعبير بهذا الطريقه تحيد على ذكاء
التنسيقيه والتنسيقيه بين البشر ترفض
مفهوم مثل مفهوم البطل لا يمكن ان يمثلها
يساري ينتمي الى فكره الخمسينات وما قبل
او حتى لا يمكن ان نقول اسلامه يعني على
سبيل المثال المشكله الان يعني حتى ولو
الكلام خارج خارج سوريا يعني عندما نقول
انه والله همم هناك مشكله مع اللاجئين
المشكله في خطاب حزب العداله والتنميه
نفسه يعني عندما تسميهم ضيوف
وتتمنى مقربه المهاجرين والانصار حقيقه
هذا غير دقيق يعني لاجئ اسمه لاجئ
وتستنادا الى هذه التسميه لديه حقوق ينبغي
لهذه الحقوق ان ان ان تقدم له بهذا المعنى
ايضا يوجد لدينا جناح يتبنى الاسلام ال-
ال- ال- المؤدلج الذي هو غير الاسلام
العادي الذي يعرف السوري بهذا المعنى ايضا
هناك ايديولوجيات اخرى يسريه وما الى ذلك
واللي بدك اياه من ايديولوجيا هذه لا
تنتمي الى ما بعد ال 2011 الاحرى الان ان
يتم اطلاق هذا الحوار العمومي وان كان
متاخرا
بالنسبه لتركيا الان دكتور همم كرشتي ماذا
عساها تفعل في ظل هذا
التعقيد في ال- في المشهد خاصه ان موضوع
المصالحه مع النظام النظام بشار الاسد
لا يعود فقط الى تركيا هناك فيتو امريكا
على ذلك هناك معارضه اوروبيه حتى موضوع
اللاجئين لا يمكن لتركيا ان ان ترتبه
بمفردها مع النظام في في دمشق هناك
معالجه تدخل فيها الامم المتحده تدخل فيها
اوروبا ايران لديها ما تقول ايضا ربما دول
العربيه اخره كيف لانقرا ان تتصرف في ظل
هذا التعقيد
للغايه واجابته هي هذه ليس مجله مصالحه
بين سوريا وتركيا
ان المجتمع الدولي ياخذ هذا الموضوع على
كانه مشكله لوجستيه ثم تابعدام اساسيان
لهذا الموضوع
العوده اذا قرر ذلك له التاكد ان هناك
لوجستك لهم تحتيه تستقبلهم وامنهم هذا
حدود جوان ضرب الاهم ولكن هناك ايضا هناك
جانب ايضا مهم اخر وهو
المصالحه مصالحه الحكومه السوريه مع مع
ابناء شعبها انا نتحدث عن حكومه غربت غربت
عجلات الملايين من مواطنيها
لدينا حوالي 10 ملايين الشخص من النازحين
خارج سوريا وحوالي نفس الرقم داخل سوريا
والتالي تقريبا تقريبا
اذا انا اعتقد وانا اقترح ان على الحكومه
السوريه عليها الان
تستوقف الراي اللقاء من كل من غادر سوريا
هو وارهابها هذا غير صحيح اصلا اللي حلها
هذه المشكله هناك
كبيره اعتقد الحكومه السوريه وسبب اهميه
ذلك هو ان تركيا هي البلد الوحيد البلد
الوحيد الذي يحزز ويقوي السلامه الاقليميه
لتركيا ككل هو اعتقد هذه ينبغي ان
يكون مهما بالنسبه للاطراف المهمه في
الحكومه السوريه هناك قوى اخرى تحاول في
الواقع ههه سامبول
تفكيك سوريا الى جوايا مختلفه عفوا
واعتقد نهايه جانب الثلاثه عندما تجمع
سويه
فانها يمكن تحقق الى التوصلين الى اي حل
يمكن يطرح على الماء على الطاوله واي
خطوات يمكن اتخاذها من قبل جميع الاطراف
الثالثه
ككل واذا كان ذلك مهم الحكومه السوريه
فلونه
نوع من التوجه بحل هذه المشكله لذلك انا
ما ادعو اليه وما اقترحه وما اتمناه هو ان
الحكومه السوريه ستقبل شرعيه شرعيه ابناء
الشعب السوري الذين
الحياه
هامه جدا وهي ان موسكو الان منشغله بالملف
الاوكراني وملف يزداد تعقيدا همم مع كل
همم يوم هل معنى ذلك بان لا ليس علينا ان
ننتظر دورا مؤثرا لروسيا كما كانت في
الاشهر الماضيه قبل النزاع اوكرانيه في
ملف همم سوري وبالتالي لا نتوقع ان تدخل
موسكو بقوه في ايه مصالحه تركيا مع النظام
في دمشق ومن ضمنها طبعا معالجه ملف
اللاجئين والنازحين
لا بالعكس انا اعتقد بان على روسيا ان
تسرع في خطواتها المتخذه على هذا السعيده
لكي ترفع عن كهيلها كما قلت في البدايه
وله جزءا من المشاكل المرتبطه بتعاملها
ومشاركتها في الازمه السوريه وبالتالي انا
اتوقع ان روسيا في المستقبل القريب ربما
ستتخذ المزيد من الجهود
لتحرير قضيه المصالحه التركيه السوريه
وربما للحصول على ضمانات من الحكومه
السوريه فيما يتعلق بشروط هذا التصالح ولا
سيما فيما يتعلق بملفه اللاجئين عموما
بالنسبه لروسيا هذه القضيه قضيه المصالحه
والتطبيع بين انقره ودمشق اصبحت قضيه مبدا
لانها لها بعد اخر بالاضافه طبعا الى
اهميه محليه واقليميه لهذا الملف بالنسبه
لروسيا المهمه ان تظهر عالم انها قادره
على حلحله همم
الازمات المتعلقه
مثلا الشرق الاوسط بوجه عام وبالازمه
السوريه بشكل خاص وهذا بالرغم من
المحاولات التي يبذلها الغرب لتهميش دور
روسيا في القضايا الدوليه
ول- اا ربما التقليل من شانها ومن مكانتها
على العالم
فقط
بهذه المقاطع لان في البرنامج ان نقوم في
نهايه البرنامج بجوله سريعه بين الضيوف
الثلاثه
لكل واحد يعطينا ما هي توقعاته ما هو
السيناريو الذي يتخيل ان الامر سيسير عليه
بالنسبه للمصالحه التركيه مع النظام في
دمشق وقضيه اللاجئين ناخذ راي سيدروف
باختصار رجاء ثم اذهب للسيد كرش جديد ثم
انهي مع شايفين هنا في الاستديو اتفضل سيد
سيد رؤوف
باختصار نعم باختصار شديد اعتقد من المبكر
جدا الان الحديث عن اي تقدم يذكر على هذا
السعيد رحمه محاولات من قبل موسكو طبعا
وتركيا وسوريا ايضا فيما يتعلق بعقد
اجتماع على مستوى وزراء الخارجيه ثم على
مستوى القمه على مستوى الرؤساء الدول ليس
المهمه هذه اللقاءات بحادتها بل المهم ما
الذي سياتي في اعقابها من اجراءات دقيقه
يعني من شانها ان تلبي وتستجيب لمصالح كل
من الاطراف الثلاثه في هذا الملف والمعقد
وهذه قضيه في غايه الصعوبه همم الدكتور
كالجرجي
همم
الاجتماع الثاني بيني وزراء الخارجيه
يتحقق في النصف الثاني من شهر يناير كانون
الثاني
طريق المصالحه احدهما مصالحه حكومه
السوريه مع ابناء شعبها ومصالحه الحكومه
السوريه مع الحكومه التركيه همم
دوله ديمقراطيه تمتلك حد ادنى من
العقلانيه الى عصابه سيصطدم بالنهايه
بالله السياسه
يعني سوف يندم اصحاب القرار على هذا
المشروع اما ال- ال- اللاجئين حقيقه يعني
اليوم صباحا قال لي صديق مثل تركي جيد
لانه انت لا تستطيع ان تبدل حصانك عندما
تخوض النهر االان يعني لو لم يبدلوا حصان
حصانهم كثيرا في هذه الفتره لكن وثقنا بكل
الكلام الذي الذي قيل ولكن نتشكك به
ولكنني شخصيه مازلت امييل وما زلت اعول
على انتصار القيم بوصفها مفهوما سياسيا
فلا يمكن فصل الاخلاق عن السياسه ما زلت
اعول ان قرار حزب العداله والتنميه باتجاه
اللاجئين سيكون سيكون انسانيه وقانوانيا
مع هذا الارث همم العظيم والارث والعمق
الوجداني الذي تتركه همم تركيا في المنطقه
وايضا ما زلت اراهن على بعض العقلانيه
التركيه الا ترمي نفسها في خارج نادي
الانسانيه انشئت الثقه بالروسي كلثقه
بالنظام السوري كالثقه بكوريا الشماليه
كلثقه بايران اكبر من ذلك شكرا جزيلا لك
دكتور مدرب دبس شكرا لك ضيفنا من انقر
الدكتور محمد عاكف كرشي وضيفنا من موسكو
يفقيني سيديروف كالعاده ننتقل الى تغريدات
حول موضوع هذه الحلقه ونبدا بهذه التغريده
للصحفيه والناشط السوري هذه العبد الله
يقول فيها طوفان بشري الاف متظاهرين
السوريين يخرجون الى الشوارع رفضا للصلح
مع الاسد 22 نقطه تظاهر في الشمال السوري
رفضا للتطبيعي مع الاسد المتظاهرون اكدوا
على ثورتهم ضد الاسد واعلن ربهم لاي صلح
او تطبيعا مع المجرم
عبد الباسط سيدرا رئيس المجلس الوطني
السوري السابق غرد قائلا هؤلاء هم اصحاب
القضيه لا الادعيه من اصحاب المشاريع
العابره للحدود البيادر في مشاريع الاخرين
ولا الانتهازيين والمتسلقين ممن لا يخشون
الله ولا يخجلون من العباد تحيه لهم اما
الرئيس السابق للائتلاف للائتلاف الوطني
الثوره والمعارضه السوريه هذه البحره
فيقول لا يمكن تحقيق اي حل قابل للاستدامه
يتجاوزوا تضحيات والتطلعات الشعب السوري
الذي سار من اجلها يتحقق السلام
والاستقرار عند ضمان سياده القانون وحقوق
الانسان وتحقيق العداله ومحاسبه المجرم
الحرب عبر التنفيذ الكامل لقرار مجلس
الامن رقم 2-2-4 وبيان جناب لعام 2012
السيناتور الامريكيه جيمس ريتش عضو لجنه
العلاقات الخارجيه بمجلس الشيوخ غرد يقول
يجب ان نراقب بعنايه المبادرات
الدبلوماسيه الاخيره بين انقره ودمشق ان
استعاده العلاقات الثنائيه لا تفعل شيئا
يذكر لاهل تركيا وتهدد الجهود الدوليه
لمحاسبه الاسد على جرائمه المروعه ضد
الشعب السوري
قد وصلنا الى نهايه هذه الحلقه موعدنا
يتجدد الاسبوع المقبل باذن الله
وسيناروهات جديده
[موسيقى]